gilles verdez qui va sauter de 92 matchs
il est très angoissé parce qu'il a très
peur du vide gilles on va le retrouver
mon fils gilles du oui serré est-ce que
tu m'entends manger oui sert il vous
entend serrer la savamment gilles
d'amours
ça va un moyen on a roulé après il
faisait chaud là maintenant je suis gelé
mais je vais le faire je vais le faire
je vais le faire on est en train de
marnach et là j'ai le promets que je
vais le faire gilles vous allez lui
était à 92 m mongil 92 m oui en fait
vous allez donc monté à 92 m c'est 40 de
plus que maxime mais j'ai le vertige moi
j vous allez le faire pour faire gagner
un voyage aux canaries
alors on va attendre d'aller là nadal à
la lan on avait l'impression mais vous
êtes sûr il y en ait merci on va d'abord
voir la vidéo de la famille c'est parti
ça lui va déjà bon anniversaire pour ses
9 ans à toi et à toute l'équipe
merci vous faire rêver j'ai un frère
qu'à 30 ans qui s'appelle genre né il ya
trois ans il a une maladie assez grave
et il est resté très digne et très fort
et en fait j'aurais voulu savoir s'il
peut être tu pouvais venir en aide par
rapport à lui sa petite famille ce qui
n'est jamais parti en vacances car si
aulas il a fallu là les ai vu tout à
l'heure
et merci d'être là en tout cas ce soir
gilles a voulu faire donc normalement il
allait partir aux canaries mais juste
avant est ce que j le montant s'il vous
plaît en régie est-ce que gilles montant
irait mongil est-ce que ça va vous
scheer est ce qu'on peut avoir des
images du régime gilles est ce que tu as
un mot à dire avant de partir à 92 m ça
tremble un peu cyril ce que je veux
c'est que les grandes cascades que j'ai
faite surtout vous continuez à me parler
parce qu'elle vous qui me rassurer
d'accord c'est et si je peux dire un
dernier mot cyril tadmor alors qu'on la
dit il s'il vous plaît qu'on vive qu'on
est il un petit peu tout seul dans sa
bulle bien entendu
[Rires]
j'ai retiré dans sa bûche j'aimerais
qu'ils sont au centre parce que c'est un
moment important d'où est-ce que vous
avez ce que gilles nous entends encore
pas tout attendre de me dira-t-on mots
pour fatou de petit mil est ce que
gilles nous entends encore oui oui je
suis là mon fils gilles nous entend ce
que j alors venez les chéris bien
entendu gilles est juste dans un bac à
sable
il est sur une balançoire va juste ap la
balançoire
est ce qu'on peut demander s'il vous
plaît je demande au public de ne pas
rigoler on va remettre le son de gilles
dans un instant et on va jeunes on
affronte broca de faire un plan large
d'où se trouve gilles vous l'épargné
j'ai mon cher est ce que tu m'entends
série lh je vous entends je peux vous
poser une question
oui je vous promets je suis un bonhomme
pour la famille je me dégonflerait pas
mais vous êtes succès en sécurité parce
que ça bouge un peu
je suis en sécurité vous êtes sur un gel
vous êtes en parfaite sécurité vous avez
été harnachés c'est ça oui j'étais
harnachés de parts on ne peut rien vous
arriver américain ce qui est tout c'est
ce que vous voulez dire à une dernière
chose à fatoumata mafate au pas tous je
t'aime je te promets fatto il me vient
dans le vide propose aux auteurs pour
une famille à 92 m fatto je t'aime je
sais que tu nous regardes si tout va
bien fat aussi la famille part aux
canaries je te promets que nos smari je
te promets que l'on se marie très vite
c'est ça pour toi
j'étais encore exceptionnellement gilles
mais attention à m'installer moi parlez
moi surtout continuer à en parler
mangent ils ont affaire à des contacts
le public massérac sac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai le mot chéri ça va quoi jeter les
maires à chaque fois moi je suis tombé à
chaque fois sa main se montre pour sa
part aux canaries
[Applaudissements]
hu
et bien sûr on a dit on a plein de
cadeaux pour le frère qui envoyait la
vidéo comme on est devant de quel os et
les devants bas on a neuf cadeau pour le
frère qui a envoyé la vidéo merci